You want your business emails to appear professional
and use the right language.
It’s especially important when applying
for jobs online, as you want to make a good
first impression.
Here are some simple tips to help you with
both formal and informal messages.
Before you begin writing your email, consider
whether you know the reader or not.
When you don’t know the reader well or you
want to be polite, it’s best to be formal
- for example, business emails, job applications,
and emails to big companies.
If you know the reader well and it’s not
a business context, you can use informal language.
You would probably be informal if you were
sending a birthday message to a friend,
for example.
Of course, the formality of the situation
may depend on the country or culture
you’re in.
It’s a good idea to get familiar with that
culture before deciding how formal or informal
you want to be.
A formal email in the UK will usually begin
with a formal starting phrase, such as ‘Dear
Mr Piper’, or ‘Dear Sir or Madam’ if
you don’t know the name of the reader.
You should also use an appropriate formal
ending phrase, such as ‘Yours sincerely’
when you know the reader, or ‘Yours faithfully’
when you don’t.
You can use more casual phrases in an informal
email.
If you’re sending a message to a friend
or family member, you might begin with a simple
‘Hi’ or ‘Hello’, and finish with ‘Thanks’,
‘See you soon’, or ‘Cheers’.
It is conventional to use a comma and start
a new line after any opening and closing phrases.
This is true whether you are being formal
or informal.
You should also be careful using slang phrases
or emojis, as these are very informal.
For example, you should never use a smiley
face in a job application, even if you want
to show that you are a very friendly person.
You should also avoid typing in all capitals,
as it looks like you are shouting.
[shouting] YOU WOULDN’T TALK LIKE THIS IN
AN OFFICE, so why do it in an email?
Subscribe to our channel for more videos on
how to improve your English language skills.